today I'll be talking about the ORS ICO
and project which connects blockchain
and AI artificial intelligence something
I'm super interested in let's start with
a problem here that ORS is dealing with
and that problem is that the
implementation of smart contracts on the
etherion platform is not secure and we
know that poor programming choices can
be fatal for businesses and consumers
the DAO hack is an example that's
relevant here and smart contracts are
yet to be proven viable in the court of
law they're probably not even legal
contracts more than likely and so on the
one hand smart contracts can have bugs
but they're not really patchable once in
the wild for the bugs that may appear
and even outside of bug smart contracts
at the moment can't change even if one
of the outside variables that relates to
the smart contract changes even
drastically and this might have nothing
to do with the accuracy of the code but
it simply cannot be changed and the
solution that IRS is proposing is called
hyper smart contracts HSC and this is
how RS conceptualizes integrating
artificial intelligence algorithms with
the decentralized storage and computing
power of blockchain contracts for
optimizing business processes this could
be the flow of goods or of information
or documents and to then automatically
release payments for executing complex
transactions for example like in a
supply chain within a business so
basically making smart contracts smarter
the token involved here is the ORS
utility token or the worst for short o
rst it's an aetherium based token
compliant with the ERC 20 standard and
the orest is used for buying and selling
hyper smart contracts and AI algorithms
and solutions and other digital assets
on the ORS si platform and marketplace
and to activate these services so you're
seeing artificial intelligence
algorithms increasingly adopted for
automatic steering and optimizing of
some business processes in real time
versus being hard-coded as seen and sort
of the problem that I described this is
part of the digitization movement and
Industry 4.0 and according to a PwC
report AI could contribute more than 15
trillion US dollars to the global
economy by 2030 that's more than the
current output of China and India
combined so the potential here is
absolutely huge blockchain technologies
also permit the avoidance of useless and
often costly intermediaries right
performance of operations in untrusted
environments obtaining certified
transactions of data and even more
generally of digital assets of different
kinds and the use of crypto currencies
can dramatically shorten payment cycles
and that could allow for the immediate
transfer of money when a smart contract
or hyper smart contracts conditions are
fulfilled this is a big deal for a lot
of small businesses and in an
accelerating digital economy the global
value chain which often has untrusted
parties within it it requires faster and
more optimized flow of goods and of
information and of payments existing
smart contracts aren't suitable for
automatically executing and optimizing
these complex business transactions a
partial part of the reason why is that
the language only features basic
arithmetic and sort of logical and
crypto operations so some use cases for
these harp hyper smart contracts include
reverse auction supply chains demand
planning and the buy anything anything
get anywhere use case with permission
blockchain which probably warrants sort
of its own video or discussion
introducing the ORS crypto Robo
financial advisor are you worried about
the value of your crypto wallet what if
your crypto currency dropped drastically
in value there is a solution
the ors crypto Robo financial aid
combining artificial intelligence with
blockchain to automatically trade and
invest in crypto assets the ORS team is
very interesting Pierluigi Riva is the
CTO he has a background in education
from the or his educational background
is from the London School of Economics
their president and executive chairman
is Fabio Xavi who we previously
interviewed on the program you can check
out that interview on our YouTube
channel Fabio has actually been invited
to speak at MIT Media Lab right down the
road from us here in Boston and the
subject of the talk blockchain + AI +
human equals magic really mirrors the
mission that we talked about with Fabio
on the program and the event seems super
interesting it's going to deal with
blockchain making it possible to have
trusted data everywhere it's going to
deal with how artificial intelligence
makes it possible to analyze and parse
and rationalize data to create value and
the concept that Fabio is going to speak
about is that when you put together
blockchain and AI you can make a lot of
things happen instantly right it and and
also dramatically more cheaply and in a
less wasteful less wasteful way overall
and it's possible that fully digital
encrypted and distributed systems can
leverage blockchain and AI to actually
disrupt a lot of current models for
asset management and capital investment
and logistical chains real estate but
the idea is let's not just trust
technology and markets to figure it out
we know that that can backfire it has
backfired many times
let's proactively design this future
world so that it fits with human needs
and nurtures the human spirit it's not
enough just to worry about the problems
that might potentially be created in a
future world let's actually look beyond
the specific problems and technologies
and build the digital ecology that makes
sense now before it gets out of hand and
this is the idea of the MIT Media Lab
event I'm going to try to get there
myself and the goal is
to develop a human strategy for
developing blockchain plus AI + human
ecology and this includes how to best
engineer and beta test the intersection
of these technologies how to plan to
promote universal adoption figure out
how to pay for it and it's going to be a
super interesting event that I'm going
to try to make it to and lastly the
token sale the main ors i CEO will now
take place from May 14th at 9 a.m.
Central European time until May 26th at
11 p.m. Central European Time o RS has
actually reduced the crowd sale duration
to 2 weeks after they collected an
initial roughly 14 million in u.s.
dollars and there are exactly 833
million 333333 arsed tokens currently in
existence out of which 500 million are
being offered for sale both at the pre
IC o---- now closed and at the main
token sale the tokens are currently
being sold for 5 euro cents each payable
in aetherium any horse available for
sale and not sold by the end of the main
token sale will be burned and for more
information about the ors token you can
visit o RS 'as frequently asked
questions page linked to in the video
description so overall very interesting
project solid token economics I've been
very interested by artificial
intelligence for a long time and the
idea of combining it with blockchain
makes this project that much more
interesting in my mind and of course
this is a review of the project and my
thoughts on what ors is doing it is not
financial advice